there's been some studies out of
Stanford University out of Berkeley on
the subject of ah appropriate for a
conference called ah and in these
studies they describe experiences of awe
as experiences of such perceptual
expansion perceptual back that you're
forced to react AMA date your mental
models of the world your mental models
of the possible in order to assimilate
the experience now there's the sense
I've talked before of the bin there
isn't done that's of the adult mind the
jaded miss that comes as we get older
and we feel like we've seen it all
before are nodding resignation into
nothingness when nothing impresses us
nothing turns us on nothing gets us out
of our comfort zone and it turns out
that experiences of ah whether they be
the first time you see the Grand Canyon
is the birth of a child or you embark on
an ayahuasca ceremony whatever it may be
you're exposed to something that is so
far beyond your conceptual frameworks
that finally you're cracked open and the
light can get in or the lighter can get
out whatever you want to call it and it
turns out that these experiences of awe
leave us with lasting cognitive benefits
so after the temporary experience
creased feelings of well-being increased
feelings of compassion increased
feelings of creativity increased
feelings of empathy not to mention that
the experience of awe acts as an
anti-inflammatory on your physiology
getting your mind blown is good for you
right as Timothy Leary is to say in
order to use your heads you've got to go
out of your mind
that the potential here to create ah
modules
sensory-deprivation floating tanks with
high-definition LED screens or wearable
helmets that allow us to completely
leave our bodies behind and have
out-of-body transformative experiences
means that the future psychotherapy
future of introspection future of how we
cultivate wellness and the self could be
radically transformed reality I mean
this is gauging I remember reading an
article by Ross Anderson called golden
eye and it was about the new James Webb
telescope and also about the Hubble
Space Telescope and he was talking about
some of the implications of what will be
made possible he was talking about how
the Space Telescope allows us to
mainline space and time through the
optic nerve I mean think about that's
really what's happening when we look
upon the Deep Field photographs right
the Hubble Deep Field photographs of the
universe we're able to fathom we're able
to hold in mind what we're looking at
that is mainlining space and time
through the optic nerve as Ross Anderson
says the sheer aesthetic force of its
discoveries right distills the complex
abstractions of astrophysics into
singular expressions of color and light
that vindicate Keith's famous couplet
beauty is truth and truth is beauty so I
read something like that and I'm like I
love language for its poetic Rhapsody
its capacity to capture see ineffable
that's just language and those are just
images
imagine a VR or AR experience that gives
people the chance to swallow the cosmos
imagine all of us being like Jodie
Foster in contact going through the
wormhole to another galaxy at the end of
time and taking all that in this is what
excites me the transformation
human consciousness that will be made
possible by these kinds of technologies
that's what it's all about
[Music]